[Music]
hello hello welcome back to et live i'm
deidre behar today we are so excited we
have one of the most successful
respected prolific artists of all time
on our couch the incomparable cheryl
crow let's give her a hand everybody
thank you
it is such an honor to have you here
thank you 35 million records nine
grammys 10 studio albums i mean how do
you feel just knowing all those
statistics i never think about it but i
have to say when i hear it i go oh my
gosh that's crazy but yeah we've been
really lucky man we've had a good run
you know 20 something years yeah still
going we we've loved you then we love
you now thank you her new album be
myself it's in stores now online now go
get it because i told you before i think
it's your best work yet thank you you
really had a blast making it did you so
much fun yes we're gonna get into it and
so much more i know you guys have tons
of burning questions just like i do
leave them below in the comments i will
get them here on my phone and we will
ask them of the lovely cheryl so let's
just dive right in okay it's been about
four years since your last album feels
like home what did you do during your
break why did you feel like you needed a
break before doing be myself well we
made the record and then i toured um so
that really
promoting the record and then touring
took the better part of a year
and then um i decided after that because
it was really taxing
promoting that record and there were
more nights away from my kids than i
will ever take i mean i will ever spend
away from them
well
in the country format you go you know
you you go to all the radio stations and
they were in school so my rule is i'm
never away from them longer than two
nights but on that you know there would
be like four nights where i'd be away
and it was just it was too hard and um
so when the whole thing was done you
know we went out in the summer and the
kids came with me i told the boys i said
we're going to stay home
and take a break for two years
and during that time i made two records
so
um
and i just made it made them during
school hours which was fantastic right
that's what i've been doing so i i know
you're a rock star you probably used to
record a lot in the wee hours of the
night yeah i don't have that luxury
anymore no yeah so you recorded this
album exclusively like walking through a
typical day um typical day
i would take the kids to school
come home work out for 30-45 minutes
meditate come down to the studio
my friend jeff trott would meet me
who and he just moved to nashville so
that was great
and we would talk for a while and then
work on some songs and we did that like
for
you know off and on for about a month
and then the record was done wow it was
great incredible six o'clock at night
break for dinner that was it
now i know that you said i think it was
when you were making come on come on
that you had to call your friend bob
dylan and you were like i need a little
bit of advice the creative juices aren't
necessarily flowing did you have that
same issue maybe making this album or
were things just kind of pouring out of
you
it was unbelievable i've never made a
record a so fast and b
um
written lyrics
so kind of prolif prolifically yeah um
i think there was just so much in the
ether there's so much um going on in all
of our lives from
what was going on with the campaign
and what it was doing to all of us and
just i don't know witnessing that and
being in that
and then also
just looking at what social media is
doing especially raising two two boys
single mom trying to figure out how to
you know navigate through that and still
have their innocence be intact and their
self-esteem and that kind of thing
all that was just kind of hanging and
as soon as we get a groove going
and jeff and i would start playing i
mean i just felt like words were just
coming out on the mic and it was really
miraculously easy and it's not usually
like that a little more writer's block
in years past now you've got a lot yeah
or more a little more like um you know
get a little more gnashing of teeth a
little more like um calculating and
perfecting and you know there was there
wasn't that much on this wow yeah come
together really quickly you touch on so
many themes i mean you said the other
night i i was privileged to go to
cheryl's show on wednesday night and it
was phenomenal
socio politically you're talking you're
talking about social media still you
know classic sheryl crow like heartbreak
records and love records
what were your inspirations going into
this album
well
i i felt like when i went in to make the
record i really wanted to have a
um a fun experience yeah and i wanted to
feel like i used to feel when i was
going to make records where it would
just be like throwing stuff into the pot
and seeing what kind of stew we came out
with and
um it did feel like that it really felt
like the old way of
recording the way i used to do it where
i would play bass and sing
and write on the mic and jeff would play
guitar and the drum programmer or
drummer whoever was with us
and we would just put it to tape and
then you know keep overdabbing and stuff
and that is basically how it happened
which is why it sounds a lot like the
early step that we did
but um
there's still a good mix there's some
more like ballady types that really like
to get the heart strings but i love the
title track so much which is a fun
upbeat song we actually have a clip of
cheryl performing be myself at the
troubadour in march it's phenomenal take
a listen
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
i love that song so much okay hold on i
have to tell you guys really quick
cheryl is cringing i mean she's got the
voice of an angel she's playing a
million instruments why do you hate
watching yourself you know
it it feels so different when you're
doing it and you're in it but then you
look at you're like oh my god uh i can't
believe i wear that shirt oh my god i'm
singing flat oh my god i look so old you
know all that stupid stuff you're
nitpicking and the whole point of the
song is being myself that is why i enjoy
doing it but not watching it okay that
is fair yes i do want to talk about the
message behind the song though the
lyrics are incredible i mean i live in
la we're guilty of it we all go to juice
bars we all uber um we're all on our
phones constantly
what is your problem with social media
do you think it's too big of a of a
challenge with us as a society today
well i mean i think my problems with it
are the problems that probably everyone
has um recognizes in that
um our iphones are
these vehicles to keep us all connected
and yet they really do create a chasm
between us you know they they rob us of
our initial
um
experience of empathy or
compassion um you know you can say
anything
on social media you can you can
exercise to
your your right to say whatever you feel
and think but anonymously which has
given a lot of people a lot of courage
to be really ugly
and um also i think the bullying thing
it's just i find that it's it's got to
be a lot harder for
kids to navigate
um with
with a gadget telling them at all times
how they should be how they should look
um
when it's already hard enough to grow up
it is you know
you mentioned kids and growing up and i
have to talk about your boys because
they're adorable
wyatt and levi how has being a mother
changed you as a human being
yeah isn't that picture cute they're a
little younger there yeah
oh my goodness yeah they're they're
seven and ten now um
you know it's changed
it's changed everything it it's it's
informed my days obviously making a
record during school hours you know
it's enhanced my life three thousand
fold um it's just
i
i mean it's just
what can i say i love them so much yeah
best decision you ever made best
decision yeah and it's just been an
unbelievable gift you know to get to be
their mom so and i tell them every day
i'm like i'm so happy i'm your mom oh so
would you encourage them following in
your footsteps are they showing musical
ability they are they love it um my
ten-year-old is really musical my
seven-year-old loves music i don't know
how musical he is yet because he's
really into sports
an athlete yeah he wants to be on the
predators of course who wouldn't right
now yes exactly
uh he doesn't want to be on the
predators um from last night oh no no
from night's past yes exactly
but um
yeah so i would encourage them i want
them to do whatever they want to do you
know i just want them to be curious
i want them to have a sense of
adventure but also have compassion and
to love the planet and you know to
understand what it means to be
present and give them all those gifts
things that you stand for yes all those
good things we're going to start taking
your questions right now because i mean
they're going nuts lots of heart eyes
everybody loves the new album which is
really great news um
sarah says you're so open about your
struggles in interviews and in music
what would you say your lowest point was
and what got you through it oh my
goodness deep question yeah sarah that's
a good one
um well
navigating the whole celebrity thing
when i feel like i'm a pretty private
person
i've had moments where it was really
challenging um about 11 years ago i had
a really big public breakup and i had
breast cancer all a diagnosis in the
same week and that was really hard
because what it did
was
i went from being
you know a well-known person
to becoming an a-lister
um you know paparazzi hanging outside my
door couldn't you know couldn't move
without people want to get to get a
picture of what i look like in my lowest
moments you know
and it really started to affect me it
made me feel
it made me lose
faith in
humankind that anybody would want to see
a picture of someone at their lowest
like that's going to really sell the
magazines
and i wound up actually moving to
nashville i was just like this is not
the place for me i can't i can't live my
life this way and it was really a great
thing it was a it was a good decision
but that was that was a hard moment and
the thing that got me through it was
actually
just learning how to
be in it to experience and not distract
myself by being busy which is kind of
what we do it's like you know just don't
think about it just
just stay busy and
you know us westerners have kind of
perfected that so i just so you
intentionally you were like i want to
deal with this i'm not going to distract
myself with music yeah i didn't make a
record i didn't go to recording i didn't
sit down and write songs i just thought
you know what i'm just going to be in it
until i'm not in in it anymore and then
one day i woke up and it was over so
would you say it's fair to say you got
yourself through that you don't
attribute it to anything well i'm a big
meditator and i have a strong faith in
god and i have a fantastic family that
i'm really close with
and good friends and so i just really
leaned on
on those things that have been a
constant in my life incredible yeah
diana wants to know we know you're
already a mom to two precious boys is
your family complete would you like to
have a baby girl
oh my gosh do you have one that you want
to give me
i mean
actually i would love to i mean if i
could adopt 10 more kids i would but
um i think our unit is perfect now
and i'm a little bit older to be a mom
and i want to have all the the energy i
can have for the two boys that i have
and um you know it'd be great to add
a you know kind of a dad type guy yeah
you know somebody who just
meets us where we are
um but you know everything is it's just
great you know i'm constantly eyes
and heart wide open so incredible yeah
you know what i love about you so much
is that
you just said a guy would only add to
the equation you're already content and
complete as it is and and i think as a
woman that that's really powerful i mean
are you are you dating is that weird now
that yeah i do but you know what it's
really nice that i i live in a place
where my kids have a very normal life
they go to school there are other kids
there that have parents that do
what my kid's parents does
i do date and i can do that
you know um
in a private setting
and it's great so you're dating and no
one even knows about it
yes it's all my business i mean
you're such a strong accomplished woman
what kind of guy catches your eye
i don't know i mean
um you know i'm attracted to people that
are funny and people that are curious
and people that are constantly on the
growing tip you know and
so um
but you know having two kids definitely
is
a
it creates a strong weed out
process like you know pretty quickly if
this is somebody that you're gonna want
to be around your kids
so
incredible yeah um
you brought up your your breast cancer
diagnosis which i mean
thank god everything's good your health
is great now knock on wood yes
um olivia newton-john just revealed that
she's now going through a second round
are you friends with her have you
reached out to her at all i've only met
her
maybe once and i i love her i have a lot
of respect for her um
and also i was a huge fan and still i'm
a fan and some wishing her the best and
you know i'm constantly telling people
particularly women because i have a very
big female fan base
make sure to know your family history
and make sure and be diligent about you
know getting your mammograms and
so until we have a cure it's early
detection is
that's the best we have totally 100 you
want to like share your well wishes well
yeah olivia i didn't know this but i
know you how strong you are and how
spiritual you are and
i know you're on top of your health so
i'm wishing you the best
incredible yeah um edward says you have
the most beautiful voice in the world oh
my gosh edward i love you i'm sure that
never gets old hearing that whatever um
oh my goodness katie wants to know
cheryl you're the ultimate woman any guy
you would be so wait any guy would be so
lucky to date you are you single oh that
is so nice katie i am currently single
yes yes single but ready to mingle
single but ready to mingle
yes work
you know you mentioned you've had some
high profile romances is that something
that's still on the table would you date
a high profile man going forward
you know i wouldn't rule it out it's
definitely
it's definitely not without its
challenges 100 and i am not i think at
this stage in my life i'm not drawn to
somebody just because they're
you know high profile
no no you're looking for a good funny
guy who's gonna make it a family
complete at four yes
um you write such incredible songs about
love and about heartbreak is there ever
any hesitation to put pen to paper i
mean people still want to know who my
favorite mistake is about i know
um no i don't feel any hesitation i
honestly
i write
um
i write from a place of
immediacy so i don't really edit myself
i mean maybe later on i'll listen to it
think oh i'm gonna have to answer
questions about this one but i you know
i just write what i write and for the
most part i think the best thing is if
you're writing from your heart there's a
really good chance that there is a
collective
um consciousness out there that can
relate well that's why what you're
writing music so much yeah
um
my goodness we've got millions more
questions coming in and we need to wrap
up soon i do want to ask about one
question on be myself i love woowoo
so much it's such a great song and i
love how candidly you speak about how
you feel empowered to sell records
through your music and a lot of artists
feel empowered to sell records
by you know being a little provocative
on stage can you kind of explain what
you mean by that and and how you
channeled it into the song well i think
there for a while it just seemed like
every time you would you know
be on social media or look in a magazine
or even here i'm very i'm very aware of
it here in
in la the the billboards it's so
different than when you go to nashville
really yeah um
yeah a lot more
um
a lot more sexuality and particularly
when it comes to
um celebrity and artists now branding is
such a big thing branding is so much
bigger than
whatever it is that you are
promoting you know you're really
promoting yourself first in the hopes
that people will follow you and then
by your
music right which is so foreign to me
i'm a bit of a dinosaur when it comes to
that
but um
the reason i wrote this song it just
seemed like there for a while
everybody's butt you know there were
pictures of every lyric but you know
so i i thought it was kind of funny and
the fact that i have two little boys who
are obsessed like every time they
a free people magazine comes in and they
see like part of a boob or something
it's just like um you know they're so
like eyeball socket retina you know just
like
and um
it's a it's a little bit of a weird
place you know for especially for young
girls to be idolizing some some of the
young artists and
and the the imagery i think in some ways
robs young girls of
a sense of innocence and it puts
pressure on the idea that this is what
power is and fame is power and celebrity
is power and
you know a big round gorgeous butt is
power and then for young boys it then
that also is you know that's what's
beautiful and
so to me because i'm older i look at it
and i just see more of the danger in it
as opposed to
um the role model the power that kind of
thing that we're supposed to be
who is doing a good job of being a good
role model i mean i love alicia keys
yeah you know i mean she's
super
strong and got a lot of talent and
you believe her she's still entertaining
yeah she's awesome
you know people like that i think are
you know kind of doing it right yeah i
mean i you get a lot of taylor swift
comparisons i'm sure
right yeah singer-songwriter she's she's
setting a pretty good example exactly
yeah okay last question before we wrap
would you be the new judge on american
idol
um
i don't know i mean if i had to move
somewhere like uh you know out of
nashville i don't know if you don't
think you could i don't know you know
it's really interesting i got asked to
do the voice before the voice even came
on that first season right oh before you
were with blake
as a as an advisor yeah oh yes oh yeah
wow yes before there was a panel i
turned it down because we had just moved
to nashville and i had
wyatt and
i didn't really want to be back to la
um you know no regrets about that i
don't you know i love my life i've had a
lot of great opportunities and i've got
i've also gotten to do a lot of things i
never in my life thought i would get to
do
i mean my bank account would obviously
be
exploding right now
but um it wasn't the right time and it
also wasn't where i was at in my head um
you know i was just really settling in
to putting roots down and
then to uproot you know and move back
to l.a
well i love the path that you're on and
the path that you chose if you haven't
gotten me myself go get it it is
absolutely outstanding it's cheryl's
best work truly in my opinion thank you
make sure you like et on facebook check
us out on youtube for more interviews
just like this with lovely stars like
sheryl crow and have a great weekend you
guys will see you next time bye
[Music]
you